[музика]
Привіт друзі Усім привіт
з вами пані Соля і
кошеня Ні ну я кажу я кошеня
каченя
я не каченя
гусеня
[музика]
гусеня ж я Хто я діточки Ану допоможіть
мені скажіть мені солі
То хто я не чую Ну
справді це ж Совеня Ну не кажи пані солі
що ти мене не впізнала впізнала впізнала
так друзі Сьогодні ми з вами будемо
говорити про ще один цікавий продукт і у
якийсь спосіб він створюється і як
потрапляє у наш з вами холодильник
що це за продукт Як ти думаєш савення Я
не думаю я знаю це молоко Сьогодні ми з
вами поговоримо про молоко Тож давайте
разом подивимося дізнаємося у який
спосіб молочком потрапляє у наші з вами
холодильники так Совеня ти собі з бочку
Посидиш А ми почнемо з того
що
потрапимо на поле де є дуже багато
різної травички і там пасуться такі
чорно-білі красиві
корівки Ану друзі Як каже корова ану
скажіть мені
так І ось наші корівки які пасуться на
полі Вони їдять багато травички
До речі цікавинка від пані солі якщо
корова їсть смачну траву той молоко буде
смачніше ви питаєтеся як зараз ми
дізнаємося в якийсь спосіб трава
пов’язана з молоком зараз дізнаємось
Отож ми з вами зараз на полі Уявіть себе
на полі і дивимося як наша Корівонька
їсть травичку їсть травичку жує
засмагає на сонечку І що я вам скажу
друзі що у нашої корівки є дуже складний
шлунок пригадуйте що таке шлунок ми з
вами раніше вивчали шлунок це такий
мішечок у нас в животику який допомагає
переробляти їжу яку ми з вами їмо
так ось
у корови дуже складний шлунок і у неї
так кажуть Навіть є начебто 4 різні
шлунки 4 уявляєте насправді це є чотири
відділених такий тут одне робиться тут
інше третя четверта і якщо в нас один
такий мішечок який зразу все переробляє
всю їжу то в корови цей шлунок є дуже
складним і кажуть наче в неї їх є аж
чотири
і От коли наша Корівонька з'їдає
травичку
[музика]
шлуночку все травичка
перетравлюється і опісля
у корови є вим'я так і в цьому вимі
збирається молоко Ось так друзі у вимі
корови збирається молоко і знаєте що
далі відбувається далі тому молока є так
багато що приходять фермери наприклад
і починають нашу корову доїти Давайте ми
зараз з вами дізнаємося як це
відбувається зараз я проведу такий
невеличкий експеримент
Ось у мене є Рукавичка
біла Рукавичка і я в неї налею молоко
справжнє молоко ми з вами уявимо Що це
власне є вим'я корови яке є ось тут ось
друзі Уявіть собі що це вим'я корови ось
цієї нашої корівоньки так і тут
зібралося дуже багато молока після того
як наша корівка наїлася травички і то її
складний шлунок тут травичку переробив
і тепер фермер давайте уявимо що я
Фермер має корову подоїти
щоб назбирати молока так і щоб це молоко
рано чи пізно потрапило у наші з вами
холодильнички тож фермер пальчиками бере
і починає доїти корову Бачите як все
відбувається ось такий спосіб ну пані
Соля такий початковий фермер тому не
завжди виходить дуже добре але Повірте
ферури які знають як доїти корову точно
вам дуже швидко надоять ціле горнятко
молока Ось так До речі можете спробувати
зробити такий експеримент вдома Я
впевнена вам сподобається Отож Ходімо
далі друзі і дізнаємося Що відбувається
далі з нашим молоком яке Ми зібрали Отож
молоко збирається на Отакі
рожеві красиві горнята як я тут вам
показала От такі величезні бідони де це
молоко пізніше
транспортується іншими словами
перевозиться Зараз я вам покажу
перевозиться ось таких великих
вантажівках
після того як молоко звичайно ж зібрали
у спеціальній лабораторії у цих
лабораторіях молоко роблять максимально
корисним перевіряють чи там немає ніяких
бактерій мікробів і чи ми пізніше
зможемо його пити в себе вдома Отож
після того як молоко наситять
максимально корисними речовинами
частину з цього молока
переливають у пляшки для молока а з
частини роблять вершки вершки це як
неначе молоко тільки вони є трохи іншими
але дуже схожі і за смаком і за зеленим
до молочка після того як наше молоко
розмістили у пляшки або в пакети або Ось
такі коробки які називаються тетрапаки
його
відправляють у мандрівку в магазини
після того в магазинах ви вже можете
побачити дуже багато різного молока так
друзі і опісля коли ви купуєте молоко в
супермаркеті воно потрапляє до нас куди
як правильно у холодильники Ось така
історія друзі
[музика]
А тепер Давайте ми пограємо в одну гру Я
зараз
назву
кілька різних страв продуктів харчування
і ви друзі маєте мені сказати які з цих
страв робляться з молока Давайте ми
зараз з вами разом подумаємо Отже
масло морозиво сир булка вівсянка йогурт
Гляньте будь ласка на ці продукти
і подивіться уважно які з них
виготовляються з молока
так уважно Уважно дивимося думаємо
дуже добре ми точно знаємо що масло
виготовляється з молока Ану покажіть як
ми мастимо хлібчик Ось так ми мастимо
хлібчик маслом так давайте ще іншу ручку
так погладимо неначе ми мастимо хлібчик
дуже добре далі друзі Скажіть мені будь
ласка що ще виготовляється з молока
вівсянка
ні молодці вівсянка - це є крупа
далі друзі Скажіть мені будь ласка що ще
виготовляється з молока молодці сир дуже
добре
А ще
правильно йогурт хто любить йогурт я
дуже люблю йогурт дуже-дуже і останнє що
Точно виготовляється з молока Ану друзі
скажіть
морозиво таке солоденьке морозиво яке
також робиться з
молочка Тепер ви знаєте як багато різних
продуктів можна зробити з молока яке нам
дає
Корівонька Ось так малята Ну що ж будемо
закінчувати давайте кличемо Совеня
Совеня Соня
ти де
ой лечу лечу УПА ні Солі ти сьогодні
фермером працювала так і друзів мені
допомагали все дуже-дуже цікаво Ну що ж
я не проти попити молочка тому мабуть
друзі буду завершувати наше заняття або
дуже хочеться мені вже попити Ну що ж
будемо прощатися па-па малюки па-па
Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами
науковиця Соломія стенка Сьогодні ми
експериментуємо і в нас тут дуже багато
різних цікавих предметів У нас тут є
тарілка з молоком
У нас тут є харчові барвники
сині і червоні і червоний До речі друзі
от знаєте якраз Перед Великоднем дуже
багато людей фарбують яйця різними
харчовими барвниками ви можете знайти
такі ідеї після ваших великодніх
приготувань Також у нас є склянка з
водою
Дві ложечки і засіб для миття посуду
дивіться друзі ці ложечки і вода Нам
потрібні для того що наші барвники є
дуже густі наче фарба нам Їх потрібно
буде трішки розчинити у воді щоб вони
гарно щось далі робили Зараз я розкажу
Так Почнемо ми з того що на ложку
наливаємо
наливаємо одну Краплю харчового барвника
або дві друзі це можна зразу робити на
тарілку з молоком Ось так хляп і хляпу
Але у зв'язку з тим що в мене ці харчові
барвники дуже густі ми їх трошки
розбавимо водичкою
Сподіваюся вона зараз все вийде так
розмішали я синій колір добре і таку
крапельку крапаємо
крапаємо другу Краплю оп
і третю Краплю
і я думаю цього нам досить так так
тепер друзі
на іншу ложку У нас є ще червоний
барвник До речі важливо що ви були
більше ніж один колір тобто може бути 2
може бути 3 або і більше Скільки у вас
там таке мають бути 10 може бути 10 Так
крапнули ми червоного кольору він в нас
також густий Як ви друзі зрозуміли
чуть-чуть розбавимо водою і
розмішаємо сюди ложкою одною допомогла
іншою то нічого
так тепер розмішуємо розмішуємо оп
тиму істочка обережно один
два крапля і нехай буде посередині три
молоко має у собі жир Так це не є як
вода вона є трішки густіше це означає що
молекули які є у молоці їх і більше ми
знаходяться щільніше а вода навпаки має
їх менше відповідно молоко є густішим а
тепер ми візьмемо нашу зубочистку
вухо
і ми на неї крапнемо трішки засоби для
миття посту і давайте подивимося що
відбудеться
не сподіваюсь вийде один
з іншого боку там де червоний два
і тепер
6 7 8 9 10 знаєте друзі Що відбувається
тут можна намалювати такі
різноманітні узори і це дуже красиво
виглядає і виходить ще фіолетовий колір
так що відбувається
засіб для миття посуду що він робить Він
змиває бруд і жир з тарілок завдяки
ньому жир розщеплюється тобто зникає
через те що молоко має у собі жир бо
молоко і жирніше ніж звичайно вода
краплі які є зверху на ньому
розчиняються розходяться розбігаються
завдяки рідині для миття посту Ось так
друзі поки юстинка грається тут ми
будемо з вами прощатися і ви теж можете
повторити такий експеримент вдома є
впевнена вам сподобається тобі
сподобалось Так супер Ну що ж по вас
[музика]